hello there ladies and gentlemen my name
is Greg and my name is John we're going
to present the movie news of the week in
six minutes or less from march six
through the eleventh Ridley Scott says
the next alien movie is already written
release gotta fainted over the years
that he ultimately plans to these movies
to connect back to the original alien
film so it looks like we won't be
getting that neill blomkamp sequel why
would I want to witness the return of
the alien franchise with favorite
characters like rip league and michael
beans Hicks who i thought had a
well-deserved in well justified F in
alien 3 yeah [ __ ] you neill blomkamp ah
q equal images from one of my favorite
movies love actually have served this
sequel coming out 14 years after the
original is called red nose day actually
let's take a look at those photos here
we got a Hugh Grant looking old and in
this one we've got martine mccutcheon
looking old as well and in this photo we
have the two actors and writer director
Richard Curtis all looking old together
and here we've got a photo of Liam
Neeson about to kick his son's ass and
Johnny English reprising his role making
this a crossover no through her Rowan
Atkinson played a different character in
connection no huh Rowan Atkinson
actually played Johnny English and
undercover as a jewelry salesman but
least least their long-term
sonai will be producing mar God Robbie's
female-driven Robin Hood reboot Marian
now Margot Robbie will play the
eponymous Maid Marian who after a
conspiracy to conquer England results in
Robin Hood's death before very eyes but
decides to pick up the cause and lead a
war by donning the Robin Hood mantle I
love women I'm glad they're finally
starring in movies I fed of the good the
correct way to Salem well Sean they keep
making these huge female-driven studio
movies now I'm just glad that women
actually get to play women now that
that's not what the controversy has been
about Steven Spielberg is set to direct
oscar-winning legends Meryl Streep and
Tom Hanks an authoress and Pentagon
Papers drama the post the story is based
on real West Vincent it plays in 1971
during which the Washington Post exposed
the so-called Pentagon Papers a secret
Department of Defense study of us
political and military involvement in
Vietnam this sounds like a great
follow-up sequel to Tom Hanks's and
Steven Spielberg's of terminal
[Laughter]
[Music]
starwars.com announced that Michael K
Williams will co-star in the Han Solo
spinoff you know the biggest rumors that
he will be playing the villain in the
zone this is ridiculous after to
ethnically diverse Star Wars movies Star
Wars is going back to be racist by
making a black guy the villain I mean
Tandy Newton is in this film and Tunnel
ever played Lando's Lando betrayed Han
and empire strikes back Star Wars is
racist three marks animation Campbell
the Hugh Jackman led animated motion
picture called larrikin go John after
you jackin with them being the Wolverine
you would never get work again that is
lazy Gentiles are all lazy Joe Jason
Momoa to set the start of the video game
adaptation of Just Cause momoa leads the
film is rico rodriguez make overt
operative who has dropped onto a
Caribbean island governed by a dictator
suspected of having weapons of mass
destruction why do you think they cast
jason momoa just god after becoming a
writer for the uncharted and x-force
moving the writer and director for the
raid remake and producing a narc TV
series joe carnahan has suddenly dropped
out of the one project we all thought
for sure would be coming out bad boys
drink I mean this is a big bummer
because I really feel like the bad boys
Ranchos needs another installments truly
wrap up their story I mean after the
events of bad boys 2 there was so many
unanswered questions left like what
[Music]
no big deal Entertainment Weekly has
released exclusive photos of marvel's
upcoming new film thor ragnarok ooh
let's take a look at those photo here we
got Cate Blanchett looking like one of
our friends and need a start Owen Loki's
back no one saw that coming and here's
Jeff Goldblum looking how he normally
looks nothing weird about that yeah so
uh where's one of Chris Hemsworth oh
right here oh my god will [ __ ] is the
why is your hair so why is much this is
a bezoar I know is Billy's I before I
know I demand my dad bumper disproved
three bucks or Ragnarok looks great Ruby
gonna suck hate everyone involved my
response is totally justified definitely
alright guys what's different the movie
d is just a week and painless if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects to get notified every
time one of our videos is out quick that
Bell quick beyond his reasons to Jerry
on Twitter and Instagram is a social
media manage it blum have some the
reality check resigned everything what
is no stagnant we gonna do